it's been a sort of slow start of the
year why do you think that it's been a
slower start is it just price related is
it
macro like fed policy interest rate
stuff yeah i think that's right i mean
you know as well as i do if you're
looking at it it's kind of been
directionless most of the year okay we
got sold off a bit everyone's worried
about the macro side
inflation of course you've got the uh
war in ukraine so
and bitcoin particularly at the moment i
mean look the whole asset class is
driven by
bitcoin we like to think that it's going
to be a store of value asset we like to
think it's going to be you know digital
gold everyone talks about it but
actually it's a risk on off asset class
so like stocks if you chart the s p or
the nasdaq versus say bitcoin you're
just seeing the same price action just a
bit of a lag so
that's meant it's been directionless i
think now um
you know doeconbina a whole bunch of
bitcoin has helped well look from the
start of the year now we're basically
hunch right so it's whatever whatever it
is now 46 000
especially unchanged in the year we're
still waiting for that
influx of real institutional money
because that's going to make it pop if
dokuan uh from tara with only three
billion dollars to say only but in the
institutional world it's not really that
much money
if he can have the impact that he's had
over the last i don't know five weeks or
whatever it's been yeah when
institutions show up with real size
does bitcoin go to a million dollars a
coin you're gonna be happy i'm not even
sure you're gonna be doing this podcast
anymore
[Music]
that's all i know
you're like david it's been nice knowing
you but i'm on a beach what do you think
happens though like it's going to
explode anthony i mean look so here
here's the i've said it again i think
before on your show
there are 200 trillion dollars of assets
in custody today that's a fact the three
biggest custodians in the world are the
three you know three three biggest
custodian banks
are you know uh state street bank of new
york mello and jp morgan they control a
hundred trillion there are 500
institutions in the world that matter
total market cap of crypto today two
trillion one percent of those assets in
custody
i know all these names are looking to
enter the market i know all their
customers and their investors want
access to crypto
so if just five percent of those assets
in custody go into crypto it's very
simple
the market cap of the asset class has to
be 10 trillion dollars that's 5x we are
today so what happens to the price
you know as i say and you uh get the
keys and lock the door here
i mean i completely agree obviously uh
what i think is fascinating i was
talking to a pretty large hedge fund
manager recently and uh his
perspective on crypto was like i'm not
anti-crypto
i just
know what i'm good at and where i have
an advantage and that's in equities and
so i'm going to stick to investing in
equities um but it's interesting to me
help me understand
and
he knew that there was 21 million
bitcoin
he understood the idea of supply demand
obviously
when i started to explain the on-chain
metrics the ability to see the
illiquidity in the market he kind of
he perked up a little bit yeah right and
he started saying
so you basically
have like the structural liquidity but
then you have like the actual market
liquidity and you can start to basically
uh analyze
which people
have what historical holding verse
selling patterns how much illiquidity
how long when did they buy what was
supposed and i was like it's all right
there on the blockchain yeah and you
could just see
him being like still equity guys yeah
but like there's more information
available here that could have better
inform
various decisions
and so when i see
when i take that as kind of an anecdotal
uh point from a conversation in your
guys metrics uh you break out the
average trade size by instrument yeah
and the chart that i'm looking at uh has
bitcoin usd versus etheusd
bitcoin usd
uh pretty much
since the beginning of last year has had
a much more significant average trade
size so that strips away how many
institutions that strips away how much
volume it's just looking at when
somebody trades what's the average size
why is bitcoin so much larger is it
because the market's larger and people
feel like there's more liquidity or is
there something else going on there 100
i mean that's that's where the liquidity
is i mean if you
you know you meet a bunch of people
asking you hey what should i buy
and you'll know a lot more coins and a
lot more assets than i will but i'm like
look if you're dipping your toe in the
water go bitcoin it's the most liquid
asset class so someone comes to us and
they want to buy 10 bucks worth of
bitcoin 10 million dollars worth
that's relatively easy to do
you try and hit that in one clip in in
ether
and you're going to move the market and
you're going to get slipped 180 200
basis points you've got to slice and
dice it you're doing smaller sizes just
that all the biggest market makers are
trading bitcoin first and again let's
look at it it's 40 to 50 percent of
the value of the total asset class so
when they first come they're making
bitcoin i think ethereum's doing better
solana is also doing better but it's
very thin and when you talk about that
institutional money coming in you just
see
huge price gaps
which
isn't good for the asset class and it's
partly what we have to try and do at
lmax group and onyx digital it's bring
bigger better institutional market
makers to get deeper liquidity across
the asset i have a customer you know
last week
literally bidding me up david look at
this slippage now all i did was buy 20
ether 20 million ether i'm like dude
this is huge you're just the biggest in
the market today
in that asset class you need to cut that
up you need to trade that in shapes of
about fifty thousand dollars
if you're lucky to get it done he can't
do it in one click he trades a bunch of
foreign exchange with me his biggest day
in fx and he was three billion dollars
and he trades in clips of
20 30 50 million and they expect to be
able to do the same in
crypto you just can't today so let's use
this hypothetical person a real person
but don't say their name um
if they trade three billion dollars in a
day and they're doing it let's just call
it 50 million uh at a pop
are they
trading to capture
one two percent moves intraday and
they're like like literally day trading
uh is it a human driving that is this
all uh kind of high frequency stuff like
walk me through what they would do in
the fx world if you trade three billion
in a day and you're trading that size
what is the goal or the trading strategy
well it depends who they are right so i
kind of have three
distinct sets of clients
you've got
banks who are basically facilitating
trades for their customers
their customers might be asset managers
portfolio managers they need to buy 100
million euros 200 million euros a
billion euros to facilitate uh
rebalancing their portfolio you've then
got brokers
a lot of broker servicing retail and
that is back to backing that flow
and then you've got the proprietary
trading firms they don't like the
terminology hft high frequency traders
but
they're just looking to gain some alpha
and get in and out they're trying to
make markets everywhere and they're
trying to nick
half the spread
but the one thing that underlies all of
that if that's too detailed too complex
for everyone is
the smartest guys are all using lg's to
execute the trades now so even
you know who's the most famous investor
in bitcoin i guess it's michael saylor
you know he's using an algo to work that
order
he's got a target price he's using a
v-wap
and by the way you can buy these on
ebay right you can buy these models if
you want to you just plug them in
and you're just trying to to have a
target price
right to let you access that so that's
really what they're all doing and no
one's pointing and clicking
um so i'd say
today 90 of all our fx volume are done
through
api and done through algorithmic trading
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time